this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbusters
summer before event movies were all
based on comic books and Tom Cruise had
to cheat death to get butts and seeds
ones onra dominated the 90 Cineplex like
no other
erotic thrillers oh yeah and also
disaster movies but only one of them
will put you deep inside the suck sowed
the suck zone twister it sucks ah
welcome to the exciting world of wind
science where experts stare thoughtfully
at the horizon while weather happens in
the distance and meet Joe and Bill a
couple of tornado scientists who used to
be merry and plan on fighting about it
anytime the wind drops below 50 I need
save I need a therapist what did I
possibly need a therapist for Joe's got
a grudge against tornadoes since they
keep trying to steal her family members
well Bill is trying to leave the stormy
life behind but also leave his fiancée
behind any chance he gets why don't you
hang out here for a little while I'll be
right back listen I'm gonna hang out
here and get some air why don't you once
you go get us some cold drinks once we
catch up with him you take the truck and
head home
I'm going back
good good together they lead a motley
crew of nerdy helpers there's rabbit the
one who's got five years left before
MapQuest takes his job Beltre
the one who quotes movies Alan the one
from that one commercial the great
Philip Seymour Hoffman as the character
Jack Black would base his entire career
on unmanly handshake ensues and the rest
of them but in a movie where people
literally outrun tornadoes the most
unbelievable thing as there are two
teams of tornado chasing scientists and
the evil one is led by the diabolical
dr. Miller who takes money in order to
do more science
Jonas went out and got himself some
corporate sponsors so at that guy right
he definitely deserves to die
yeah take that funding strap in for one
of the biggest action juggernauts of
1996 a movie that largely consists of
people driving toward a storm then
immediately yelling get out of there
once they get close you're chasing it
what did you think was gonna happen in
this cautionary tale that reminds
audiences everywhere the greatest danger
in a tornado isn't the tornado itself
you can probably just hunker down and
let it pass right over you
no the real killer is sparse
[Music]
I hope they put an end to those darn
sparks but only with their own money no
corporate sellout scientists so enjoy
this white-knuckle adventure slash
relationship drama about sad lonely
divorcees from an era where movies with
a hundred million dollar budgets didn't
need to kick off a franchise or adapt
some IPE and when they destroyed some
they really destroyed some
and return to a golden age when a film
could be based on the whim of a studio
exec who flipped channels to a tornado
dog on National Geographic yeah he's a
storm chaser plus his wife's always on
his ass or something I don't know get
cried nun I will figure something out
story that's it man game over man game
over
Joe versus the tornado
[Music]
dr. girlfriend Gustin Hoffman armbar oh
never a boring ride with Alan rug dr.
Daniel Fahrenheit moved get out the way
Oh house hunters Oklahoma
and meteorology slang it's patty time
going great great it's only a section
scam in that cell keep looking for a
well these planners one of my new points
doing the bow so to being north east of
81 rotation is increasing shears 90
knots 50 outbound 40 inbound flanking
line okay we got sisters oh yes
definitely a sidewinder what's the core
the cone of silence
he gave velocities are max Bell those
are just down drafts and my broker's
yeah and don't forget to pull out the
Doozer knob when you gonna tip the
phalanges marriage stormy this is easily
the second funniest movie about the wind
trying to kill you Troy and Abed in the
mornin curse your sudden but inevitable
betrayal baby I hear the Blues are
calling toss salads and scrambled eggs
starring Chris Hemsworth in ABS the
movie Pat you're the greatest husband a
lady could ask for
happy 10-year anniversary